[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
aujourd'hui la pma santerre et la
gestation pour autrui représente un
formidable business
donc vous avez forcément des cliniques
privées qui ont de gros moyens
financiers qui ont intérêt à ce que ces
textes évidemment soit voté pour
favoriser leur développement commercial
et c'est un des points contre lesquelles
nous mobilisons aujourd'hui c'est ce
business de la fertilité qui est fait
pour des gens qui ne souffre pas
l'infertilité aujourd'hui simplement
parce qu'ils veulent pouvoir choisir la
couleur des yeux ou la couleur des
cheveux de leurs enfants
elle va nous considérons que c'est
injuste nous considérons que c'est ça ne
respecte pas la dignité ni les femmes ni
des enfants et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la manif pour tous et marchons
enfants restera mobilisée contre ce
texte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]